this scene was just insane i thought the  way that introduced the dragons into the  scene was fantastic with characters  slowly coming into scene and cyrex being  revealed through the cloudy mist i just  thought the cinematography and attention  and anticipation created here was just  fantastic and gives me a lot of hope  that the dragons are going to be  utilized extremely well in this series  another thing i really like about the  dragons is they so far seem to have  different distinct personalities and  also they all seem to have different  unique designs like karaxis just looks  like such a badass whereas the dragons  in the original game of thrones series  all seemed kind of the same but anyway  let me know what you guys thought about  the scene in the comment section below  and how do you feel about the dragon so  far and you haven't already please do  consider subscribing thanks for watching  guys